- Everybody, I'm hanging Penn & Teller!
Give it up! (clapping)
All right, so with what do you
guys have to show us today?
You look so crazy, man.
(Penn laughing)
I love you.
- Sometimes X equals X.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughs)
- I'm gonna take three
of these grapefruit,
and we've written names of
some of your songs on here.
Now, we've got "Stronger",
"Piece By Piece",
"A Moment Like This,"
You wanna change any one of these
for any one of those there?
I want you to have a free
choice of grapefruit.
- No! I like dealer's choice.
Let's pick the ones you did!
- [Penn] So you want
me to take these three?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- With these three?
Now I'm gonna have you,
- [Kelly] Those are heavy, too!
I'm gonna ask you a few questions, there.
I want you to name a
number between one and 10.
Now, most people name seven.
That's the number they name the most,
but you can name any number you want.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, or 10?
What would you like?
- Four.
- [Penn] Four.
Wanna change your mind?
- Nope.
- [Penn] Sure?
- Yep, very sure.
- Okay, want black or red?
- What!?
- [Penn] Black or red?
- Oh, red.
- [Penn] Red. Okay, you
wanna change your mind?
- No.
- You want diamonds or hearts?
- Diamonds! April, hello.
- [Penn] Diamonds?
- Yes.
- Wanna change your mind?
- [Kelly] No.
- Did you say the four of diamonds?
- [Kelly] Four of diamonds.
- [Penn] Four of diamonds
is what you've chose.
You wanna change your mind?
- [Kelly] No!
- You're gonna think back on this.
You wanna change your mind?
- No.
- [Penn] Okay.
Now, I've got these three songs, here.
Which one do you want,
there? Name one of them.
- "Stronger"!
- [Penn] Say "Stronger"? Okay.
You ready, Teller? Here comes "Stronger".
- [Kelly] (gasps) Okay.
- [Penn] And we have two others, here.
We got "Stronger" on the knife,
we got "A Moment Like This,
and "Piece By Piece", here.
Now, I want you to see this one, here.
If we took this and cut it open like so,
you would see, in the middle of that,
you would see nothing but
citrus goodness, there.
Now, if we took this one,
"A Moment Like This",
and cut this one open,
you would see nothing in
there, but citrus goodness,
but "Stronger", which
is the one you chose,
- [Kelly] Oh my God,
if the four diamonds is in there, get out.
- [Penn] Could be.
There is something in
there, no doubt about it.
- If the fricking card is in it,
- Let's see what the,
- [Kelly] What?!
- [Penn] Looks like the
fricking card is in there.
- If that is the four of diamonds,
you get the hell out, right now!
- Let me just remember how we picked this.
Now, you said four.
I asked you, Kelly, to
change your mind, didn't I?
- You did, and I am stubborn!
I'm a Taurus.
- [Penn] Then I said red, you said red,
I said, "Change your mind."
You could have gone to black.
I even told you, you know?
And then I said,
"Hearts or diamonds?"
- Oh my God,
it's the four of diamonds, isn't it?
And also, you picked
the grapefruit, right?
Could have been any of these songs.
You could have done "Walk Away",
- [Kelly] No, I don't understand.
- [Penn] But you didn't do any of that.
- I don't understand.
- [Penn] And here, in
this citrusy goodness,
what was the card you said, again?
- [Kelly] No way.
- [Penn] Way!
- [Kelly] What?!
- [Penn] Way.
- I don't understand how you do that!
- [Penn] There it is, right there.
There it is, right there,
and we can even keep our safe distance.
- [Kelly] You guys, this is the real card.
- [Penn] Yes, it has good citrusy smell.
- [Kelly] I don't understand it.
- [Penn] It's a trick!
- It's such a good one!
- We were lying to you!
- It is such a good one!
- Oh, thank you!
- How in the world did
you know? That's amazing!
- [Penn] You're just such
a four of diamonds gal!
- [Kelly] I am such a fool!
I didn't see what you did there,
but oh my God, that was incredible.
That's a fricking four of diamonds.
What the hell just happened?
(audience cheering)
Thank you guys so much! That was amazing.
So, be sure to watch
the "Fool Us" Christmas
special December 16th,
I'm freaking out, and look
out for the new season
starting January 8th on the CW.